well if it isn't another season of from
coming to an end
and I think I found out the problem of
the show the problem is there's too much
we don't know well that's putting it
lightly Jade thankfully I've spent too
much time re-watching this season over
and over again searching for Clues on
just what the hell is going on and in
this video we'll be taking a deep dive
into its ending and what it could mean
for season three and yes I'll be
sprinkling in new information about that
cryptic season one cave painting as we
go along as always I've left timestamps
below to all the topics I'll be covering
now get ready to climb the lighthouse
because here we go last episode left us
with Julie Marielle and Randall looking
like me after trying to figure out
what's going on it appears they are the
three chosen to replace the three bodies
from the medieval chamber Boyd
discovered in the first two episodes and
they are connected to the first three
lines of the nursery rhyme heard in
episode 8. they touch they break they
steal Marielle stole morphine Randall
pretty much breaks everything around him
and he also stole Donna's car keys and
tossed them into the forest this leaves
us with Julie she hasn't really broken
or stolen anything of note so she may
fall under touch having touched the
hearts of several of the townspeople
will even see her wearing a sweater full
of Hearts she's cheered Elgin up and is
always there for her brother this may
all sound like a bit of a stretch but
that's all we really have to go on at
the moment when Boyd traveled to the
medieval chamber in episode 2 he saw
that two out of the three captives were
already dead with Martin the emaciated
Marine soon to follow Martin's death
seems to have put in motion a sequence
of events which led to the emergence of
the cicadas and the town eventually
shifting toward winter remember Victor
told us that up until now the town had
been in a Perpetual state of Summer what
I found interesting however was Martin
didn't have those creepy gray eyes why
did Julie Randall and Marielle have them
but not him Martin also leaves us with a
bunch of unanswered questions who kept
him there how did he know about Boyd's
wife Abby and how did he get infected by
those worms which you'll later pass on
to Boyd we also don't know if our curse
3 saw anything while in their Comas we
see them scream reacting to something
but will any of them have memories of
what happened when they were unconscious
when Boyd finally breaks the music box
it seems to release the three from their
spell but as the ghost aboid's wife will
warn him this only delays the inevitable
later on in the video I'll talk a bit
more about who's orchestrating this
spell and their motives in doing so the
finale also reintroduces us to the boy
in white we haven't seen since the
finale of season one Victor tells
Tabitha that it was the boy in white who
told him to wait in the caves for her in
the finale if this is true it implies
that he can foresee the future Victor
also knew the amount of graves to make
the night colony house was attacked so
this information probably came from the
boy in white while searching through the
forest Boyd wants to know if Sarah knows
anything about this boy in white to
which she responds I don't think he
really was a little boy quote unquote
boy is likely decades old and doesn't
age he's the same age when Victor finds
the town has been massacred and judging
by his clothing it looks like he could
have been born anytime from the early
1900s to 50s while the boy in white
seems to be evil by pushing Tabitha out
of the White House he first apologizes
stating that this is the only way this
is the only way to save them all and
just a reminder before we go any further
if you like these types of videos give
it a like And subscribe I do deep Dives
on tons of other shows when Sarah
arrives at the ruins of the chamber she
says this is where the music box is but
more ominously she can hear the screams
of Julie Randall and Marielle whoever or
whatever has a hold of them is hurting
them and quote needs them to stay it's
almost as if whatever entity this is
feeds off their pain and suffering when
the monsters kill they too play with
their victims and make them suffer they
get enjoyment out of it
they said they wanted
play with me Sarah also confirms that
the entity is laughing at Boyd for
setting him free referencing how he
brought the worms into town triggering
this situation we'll see Sarah
experience a nosebleed after this the
same thing that happened to Tabitha
after seeing visions of the ghost
children in episode 5. throughout the
season I've had my eye on Tilly there's
just been something about her that rubs
me the wrong way she somehow knew Fatima
was pregnant which triggered Elgin to
remember his dream about the boy in
white she knew about Boyd in his
Adventure in the forest even though she
had just gotten into town and she just
so happens to drop off the morphine
which Mario would later steal for her
drug addiction one of the interesting
things we learned about her in the
penultimate episode was that she had
seven grandchildren and it just so
happens there are seven children in the
cave when Jade visits and seven people
in the prayer circle when she recites a
Psalm Psalm 23 4 a passage from the
Bible which emphasizes trust in a higher
power in the presence of fear and evil
she was also so pretty damn happy when
she arrived in town dancing in the rain
although that could be explained as her
just enjoying some of her last moments
with nature as she'll later tell Christy
she was diagnosed with some incurable
disease if we go back to the cave
drawings from the season one finale
we'll also see seven black rectangles
underneath the root symbol Jade will see
this image along with the seven children
now throughout the season Tabitha has
been on her own Journey leading her on a
quest to the lighthouse it first started
with visions of ghost children and
uncovering Victor's sister's drawings
and an obsession with one drawing in
particular that of the lighthouse
according to Victor this is where his
mother went the night she died and she
went there to save the children in an
attempt to free everyone in town now
Victor doesn't know where the lighthouse
is but he does know where his mother
went the night she went missing the
Bottle Tree the first time we saw the
Bottle Tree was in episode 9 of season
one but the tree in this episode is
markedly different the season 1 country
is thinner and doesn't have a far away
hole in it is it the same tree and has
just changed or are there two possibly
even more bottle trees littered around
the forest Boyd will show Sarah that he
managed to grab one of the bottles and
inside written on a piece of bark is the
number 1864. 1864 is also one of the
years written in Tabitha's Lighthouse
stream from season one the latest date
there 1978 could be the year Victor
emerged to find the town massacred
leaving me to believe all these dates
are years in which a big catastrophic
event occurs we'll even see a bottle
littered on the stairway which Tabitha
accidentally kicks down the stairs just
another clue that these bottles are
somehow connected to the lighthouse
lighthouses are also meant to guide ship
sin to help them avoid dangerous rocks
and land while messages in bottles
Traverse the sea so there's a little
connection there the lighthouse can also
be seen in the cave drawing in season
one it seems to be guiding people on
ships down a river they have their hands
up in the air perhaps in distress or
celebration at finding land around it
appear to be triangle-shaped mountains
and trees the earliest year we saw
engraved in the stone of the lighthouse
was the year 1506 so maybe these are
lost explorers from Europe celebrating
finding land only to find out they've
come to this cursed place but things
like fresnel lenses like those found in
the lighthouse weren't invented until
the 1820s but remember things don't
really make a lot of sense here so it's
completely possible one thing I didn't
spend too much time talking in my season
one cave analysis video are the
conscious use of different colors three
to be exact red white and black white
seems to symbolize real living things in
nature we have people trees mountains
and birds black seems to represent the
supernatural the root symbols seven
children platforms and maybe this is
that whole Boyd was stuck in at the end
of season one or where he'll eventually
find the Talisman and finally there is
red meaning danger or perhaps evil we
have the lighthouse where the kids were
supposedly held this huge ominous figure
who I think is the evil entity
controlling the place and you'll see
some red human figures dancing around
whether they be evil people or Monsters
who knows Tabitha wants to go on this
journey because she knows how doing
nothing won't solve anything she waited
around when their son Thomas was ill and
that got her nowhere so now she's not
going to do the same thing when Julie is
ill and can we just take a moment to
recognize how amazing Victor Was
preparing a lunchbox of snacks for her
Victor notices that this tree isn't
where it used to be in season one he
remarked that the trees have a habit of
moving hence why he enlists Ethan to
track down their movement now this
particular Faraway tree is different
when you enter a normal Faraway tree you
never know where you're gonna end up but
apparently this tree takes you outside
the lighthouse every single time as
Tabitha Ventures up the lighthouse
staircase you'll see the same children's
dump truck and playing cards there's a
bunch of Gears which seem to to be
operating the fresnel light at the top
but take a look at this is it just me or
does it look like there could be a map
display on the bottom of the light I
mean it's possible it could be rust but
I'm just throwing it out there a lot of
the lenses seem to be bashed open as
well but the thing I found most strange
no water at least from the angles we
were given there's a lighthouse in the
middle of a forest next to no water we
see Jade smashing bottles which he had
previously formed into the shape of the
symbol he's become obsessed with this
symbol ever since seeing it carved in
blood on a tree near the civil war
soldier he'll even be haunted by
Christopher the supposed evil man who
had something to do with Victor's mom's
death as well as the towns Victor tells
us that Christopher used to be a nice
man and made everyone laugh until he saw
that symbol maybe Christopher was the
owner of that ventriloquist dummy who
keeps haunting Jade so Jade is smashing
these bottles in an attempt to get a
different perspective on what this
symbol could mean when he's haunted by
Tom the dead bartender who died by a
monster after being crushed by Jim and
Tabitha's house that's a sentence ghosts
are pretty common in town Boyd's been
visited by the ghost of father caughtry
and his dead wife whether this ghost is
good or evil who knows but he definitely
wants to help Jade find that symbol
pushing him to venture into the cave
outside the cave we see this blue bike
it either means that someone else is in
there or perhaps Jade took this bike
there is a blue bike in the background
of this shot outside Tan's house so who
knows inside the cave Jade is haunted by
the voices of the children reciting the
word ankui the cryptic word first heard
by Tabitha this word has yet to be
cracked from anyone in the from fandom
I've personally tried rearranging the
letters and searching for its origin to
no avail in the subtitles it's spelled
this way however user an imperfect
stranger on Reddit theorized this
spelling may be wrong for if you spell
it the Latin way its translation sounds
almost identical listen to this and it
translates to this one so no
confirmation on this but it's the best I
have so far Jade is treated to a
horrific vision of the children on these
almost sacrificial beds staring up into
the sky as this symbol takes the form of
roots at first it wasn't there but when
the kids arrive boom personally these
roots also look pretty disgusting and
almost worm-like and worms were seen in
the finale of season 1 and also in
Boyd's skin no telling where these roots
lead but if I had to Hazard a guess it
could be the Bottle Tree or some other
far away tree perhaps these roots create
a network of Faraway trees and as quick
as the kids came they vanished leaving
Jade and me like my life more than
any other episode the finale tackles
grander themes of chaos and fate and
light and darkness Boyd mentions that
katri never lost faith even in his dying
moments in season 1 episode 6 katri says
chaos and faith
that is the duality of our existence
Jade brings up chaos theory that even
though things may seem chaotic it's all
part of a big beautiful plan Christy
used to believe in a grand design but
now she doesn't with Kenny countering
with the saying of his fathers it's hard
to see the sweater when you're only just
a threat it's a metaphor for the show
itself even though everything seems
chaotic and that it doesn't make sense
we're just a thread unable to see this
sweater or the grander pitcher the
episode also placed a lot of emphasis on
light and darkness in their marriage
ceremony Ellis talks about Fatima being
his light that guides him through the
darkness this prompts boy to gather his
torch and make his way back to the ruins
light and dark places
I gotta go this light somehow reveals
the chamber where their music box is but
before he destroys it he's visited by
the ghost of his dead wife the same
ghost that beckoned him to join her last
episode I don't really think this is his
dead wife rather The Entity using her
image to bend Boyd to his will so we
can't really take anything it says at
face value will the people of the Town
actually suffer if he destroys that box
according to this ghost The Entity wants
the townspeople to have hope because
it's the presence of Hope which allows
them to suffer and suffering is what
this entity feeds on she refers to the
forest as needing to be fed not by fear
but by hope Boyd rejects this and
smashes the music box which releases
Julie Randall and Marielle from their
suffering the theme of Good and Evil
light and dark was found in the
television show Lost with showrunner
Jeff pinkner of Fromm also worked on
it's possible that good or light has
manifested in a person or people with
the good being the boy in white well
that dark evil into this yet to be seen
entity well coming back to the
quote-unquote real world Boyd finds a
German Shepherd watching him almost as
if this dog wants boy to follow him this
isn't the first time we've seen this dog
it appears to belong to the boy in white
and like him doesn't age since we see
him in Victor's flashback as a child
Victors even made drawings of him but
there's this other cryptic drawing
showing what could be Victor and his mom
or his sister next to a dog and this
calls into question whether the dog is
really the boy in white or Victor's
while searching for Ethan in season 1
Jim and Tabitha find the dog in the
forest and in episode 8 of season 1 it
was a German Shepherd void followed
which led him to the discovery of the
Talisman so it appears this dog has good
intentions finally the thing everyone's
going to be talking about Tabitha waking
up in the hospital after venturing up
the lighthouse and hearing The Whispers
of the children saying ankui she is
thrown off the top by the boy in white
only to awaken in the real world
according to the doctor she was bound
three days ago by a group of hikers in
the forest it's important to note here
that Tabitha is never mentioned by name
so we're unsure if the doctor actually
knows her identity there's also no sign
of her family on the computer screen we
can make out the name of the hospital
Saint Anthony's Saint Anthony is the
patron saint of lost and stolen articles
which I found rather interesting since
all our characters are lost Tabitha's
body being found in a forest also
eliminates the theory that residents of
the town are all in some sort of coma or
dream state what I'm really curious
about is if everyone who dies in town
magically shows up back in the real
world or if it can only be done under
specific circumstances I personally
think it would be a cop-out if you
killed yourself and boom you're back in
the real world when Tabitha looks
outside she sees a Seaside or Lakeside
Town we're not really sure if this is an
American town a Canadian one since the
show is set in Nova Scotia or a
fictitious one created for the show
regardless it looks like Tabitha will be
on a journey to get back to town and
save her family perhaps even meeting up
with previous Town citizens who managed
to escape or maybe even died leaving the
possibility for father caughtry and Abby
to come back I wonder if we'll also meet
adult Eloise we never really found out
what happened to her after she chased
after her mother so as the season comes
to an end we are once again left with
more questions and answers but with
Tabitha being in the outside world I'm
hoping next season provides us with some
big Revelations but now I turn it over
to you what did you think of from season
two leave your thoughts and theories in
the comments below thanks for watching
please be sure to like And subscribe and
for more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember my wife
thank you